avec nous helenavolochine ancienne
correspondance 24 à Moscou bonjour Elena
le dernier urgent le QG de Wagner assure
qu'il opère normalement deux jours après
la rébellion avortée elle va tout va
bien finalement
on a le sentiment que la journée de
samedi ne pas déroulée en fait
exactement alors du côté du régime qui a
donc fortement vacillé effectivement on
ne peut pas dire autre chose que la
communication extrêmement verrouillée
avec des images de Shogo diffusés dont
on ne sait pas de quand telle date sans
son ce qui témoigne d'une crise profonde
parce que c'est vraiment très grave
lorsque les leçons des vidéos sur les
vidéos du ministère de la Défense est
coupée ça veut dire que voilà s'il y a
vraiment on est en train de tout
simplement de de cacher quelque chose
alors voilà quand où cette vidéo a été
tournée qu'est-ce qui se dit et autre
image non pas cette fois sans son mais
sans images si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
c'est celle là de Vladimir Poutine avec
en train de de soi-disant tenir avoir
économique seulement Vladimir Poutine
lorsqu'il tient des réunions en
visioconférence en visioconférence on
voit toujours la partie en face là il
est tout seul donc c'est la première
fois je pensais qu'il était en train de
quand j'ai juste vu l'image que je n'ai
pas encore écouté ce qu'il disait je
pensais qu'il était en train de faire
une allocution là c'est le format à
locution ce n'est pas le format con
conférence donc on coupe le son on coupe
l'image les chaînes de télévision russe
ne diffusent plus à l'infini leur leur
tergiversation sur les nazis l'OTAN etc
ça cache seulement des communiqués
officielles bien sûr donc le régime là
tout est verrouillé à fait face à
quelque chose de très grave ce sont
déstabilisé voilà pour le régime l'heure
est grave pour Wagner
il y a
aussi un côté ou on doit remettre en
place une certaine communication le fait
que pour le moment il y a cette
communication là des deux côtés c'est à
dire le Kremlin qui dit
tout va bien et frigogine qui dit tout
va bien cela tend quand même à penser
qu'il y a véritablement eu un accord et
non pas d'autres causes qui ont fait que
pregoji n'a fait demi-tour et n'est pas
allé jusqu'à Moscou exécuter son plan il
y a peut-être eu un compromis voilà sur
le fait que là pour le moment chacun
devait revenir enfin en tout cas du
moins Prigogine devait revenir sur ces
positions entre Poutine et Prigogine
je ne sais pas si c'est Poutine si ce
sont les services de Poutine enfin qui
qui nous met en a trouvé à trouver le
compromis en tout cas on a entendu le
président belorus Alexandre lucaschenko
dire voilà je récupère Prigogine mais
enfin bon Alexandre le cachenko dans
cette histoire c'est un proxy c'est un
passage c'est un peu une figure écran
qui a joué le rôle tout simplement de de
de
d'écrire une certaine légende pour cette
histoire avec une fin heureuse comme
quoi il y avait gagné Prigogine aller se
réfugier disparaître en Biélorussie le
fait que là on a l'impression que du
côté de Wagner ils sont en train encore
de jouer le jeu on n'a pas vu Prigogine
depuis cette crise on ne lui Wagner vous
dit vous le disiez on sont en train de
dire on est rentré sur nos bases
normalement
il y avait une trilogie m'avait dit on
fait demi-tour selon le plan donc ce
plan ce serait justement les termes de
cet accord maintenant quelles ont été le
terme du compromis est-ce qu'il sera
respecté ça on n'en sait rien le sort de
de trigogine Poutine avait dit on
abandonne les ensuite là on apprend
qu'il y a une enquête qui se poursuit au
pénal est-ce que ce soir est secondaire
pour vous alors c'est l'enquête pour moi
qui est secondaire pour le moment et je
parce que l'enquête c'est c'est juste un
effet d'annonce c'est cette espèce de
village potenking d'Etat russe qui
continue de fonctionner normalement
voilà il y a une enquête judiciaire dans
un état de droit on va c'est un mutin
donc on va venir l'arrêter chez lui on
va lui mettre des menottes on va le
juger il y aura un procès il ira en
prison bon l'enquête c'est c'est comme
le son d'ouverture comme ça fermeture ça
donne change rien à la réalité de ce qui
se passe dans le monde réel donc ça il
faut vraiment le comprendre son sort
aujourd'hui c'est qui va le protéger
est-ce que quelqu'un va lui venir lui
mettre une balle dans la tête est-ce que
quelqu'un va venir l'empoisonner est-ce
que c'est lui qui va refaire une
tentative dans combien de temps c'est ça
la question s'en sort
le régime de Vladimir Poutine ne peut
pas venir arrêter en tout cas tout peut
arriver chez Vladimir Poutine en Russie
mais on a du mal à imaginer en tout cas
brigogine ayant la garde rapprochée
qu'il possède que quelqu'un pourrait
venir l'arrêter pour aller le mettre
devant un tribunal ce qui est sûr c'est
que encore une fois s'il compromis il y
a eu et que il y avait gagné prigogne à
donner la promesse de ne pas éliminer ou
en tout cas de ne pas remarcher sur
Moscou ça ne veut pas dire non plus
qu'il va tenir enfin là voilà on pose
des questions mais il faut juste
accepter que aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
réponse on est dans l'incertitude on est
dans l'incertitude on est dans la
confusion totale mais le pouvoir
aujourd'hui en coulisses est en train de
chanceler ça on peut l'affirmer en
Russie voilà c'est il faut il faut il
faut s'en tenir à ça qu'est-ce qu'il y a
eu faut je sais qu'on a envie de poser
les questions et on pose les questions
normalement de qu'est-ce qu'il y aura
mais on s'en tient pour le moment à
qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu il y a une
tentative de coup d'État il y a un coup
d'État qui a échoué puisque il a fait
demi-tour on ne sait pas pourquoi on ne
sait pas pourquoi
on sait je m'avance à dire que l'on sait
qu'il a eu des soutiens il n'a pas je
pense qu'il n'a pas agi seul enfin c'est
pas je pense c'est on ne peut pas dire
qu'il agit seul qui sont les quels sont
les forces qui ont en gros la question
qui veut aujourd'hui la tête de Vladimir
Poutine en Russie elle est très
importante et il y a des forces qui
veulent destituer le régime qui ne sont
pas que du côté du bras armé qui a été
il y a gagné Prigogine et ça c'est ce
qu'il faut vraiment garder en tête c'est
à dire que c'est une situation qui est
extrêmement grave une crise sans
précédent pour un autre symptôme si l'on
peut dire on avait douglaserberte qui a
vécu le coup d'État le la tentative de
putsch avorté en 91 lorsque
la télévision russe diffusait le Lac des
cygnes on est dans cette situation là
c'est à dire que la télévision en
continu aussi à 24 diffuse des
documentaires historiques donc voilà on
est accéléré dans les heures qui
viennent peut-être rien n'est exclu on
ne sait pas ça peut prendre des mois ça
peut prendre des mois mais on est dans
un moment charnière de l'histoire et on
n'a pas d'heure et de date pour savoir
quand est-ce que ça va basculer voilà la
prudence bienvenue d'Helena voloshi
merci beaucoup Elena pour votre
commentaire